[Music]
[Applause]
that was the ugliest face I have ever
seen joy
[Applause]
you look ridiculous you screams green
hair be excited yeah five out of ten
who's really excited like a 30th 30th
who's ten out of ten excited okay I
don't really know what I'm Ryland you up
for it's really gonna be a boring panel
after we're done with this
I got nothing planned oh and in case you
were wondering yes I'm wearing a GoPro
so when I go into the audience you will
be filmed so I'll be ready for that the
original idea and this was shot down by
everyone else I notice is this harness
on the chest but I took it off it
actually fit on the legs for some reason
no one approved it they wouldn't let me
do the Kamat scam Oh Bobby you would
approve the cross camera yeah Oh No Ken
Bob get his mic please Mike - Mike -
please I have to sit down again oh there
it is hello
we're trying we're trying to announce
that we're going to be live oh yeah our
poets are working this is being streamed
to the internet right now public yeah so
all of your non excitedness will be
reported to the world that everyone will
be jealous that they weren't here and
you got to be here so you better be
excited I can't hear you I can hear them
just fine yeah yeah I heard that way too
I don't see anything but I might we
didn't work I don't have data I don't
know why I said that to the mic
yeah yeah all right wait in between I
just got it so I went out yeah I'll
retweet that everyone if you're going to
Twitter right now check out like if you
want to help out and retweet the live
stream link like we're trying to get it
so everyone can watch how long do people
walking in you guys hello there my
favorite hi
they came in the back door - so
deceptive it's not that kind of panel
yes
not yet anyway it'll get there it
definitely will get there it's almost
time but unfortunately we're still
filtering people in here so we're not
gonna be able to start it just right
away but I've got a very special
surprise because I tease this sketch
comedy that we just did where Worf - is
finally making the appearance and you
guys are gonna be able to see it before
anybody else does well then everyone
that watches the stream but it'll be
early so no one will be there yet so
you'll be really exclusive got really
quiet
thank you yes who is excited you yeah
yeah in case you didn't know this is
column B the middle ones column C and
the far ones column a and you're all
competing against each other we've got
wit ya go column a talk about yeah come
B what do you guys say about that
yeah call em c-come on
that's pretty good that's pretty good
you guys that the representatives Colome
they're the only ones excited we have
some call overseas hiding over in column
a yeah all right so why is it a PC shut
up
don't ask it's a B C okay I like a haze
real nice Hey good okay so I'm gonna do
is we're gonna do something complicated
you got to pay attention because
otherwise you're not gonna get in you're
gonna mess up and you look like an idiot
my job but whatever so what we're gonna
do we're gonna start with B over here
we're gonna do the way but we're gonna
complicate it wait we're gonna start
from the front of me go all the way to
the back then we're gonna start the back
of C and go all the way to the front
then we're gonna go this cup a and we're
gonna go all the way to the back
you ready your eye is all up to you you
have to do this three two go
yeah oh it's coming it's coming
[Applause]
it worked
all right you feel good about yourselves
you did one thing and you did it yeah
our here's the next task we got what
time is it right now
that's right now Jane Tom 32 Mars what
huh huh
132 thank you I got it but thank you all
right so what we're gonna do is we never
keep a track of the time in here so I
wanted to come up with a better way to
do that and I figured the Beth boom the
bed the best way would be for you guys
to let us know so what I want thank you
thanks for the update not what I wanted
what I need from you guys is gonna be
complicated I want you guys to give me
your best wails of the Damned like oh
[Music]
yeah give me that give me that give me
that more more more more than more scary
more scarier but real quiet do it real
quiet that's good sounds like booing
that's what I lived here
so what every 10 minutes
so in have 140 just everyone watch your
clocks just start doing that like real
start real quiet and then just build up
and that way we'll know when time has
passed there's gonna be a really
sentimental moment it's gonna be
interrupted by whatever hey it's gonna
happen to my panel you do whatever I
want my names on it you're just and
friends
[Music]
I'm sorry I love you guys thank you much
better I love you too you're darn right
you do
are we all in here yet are we in here
that can I get a thumbs up three two one
got it good okay everybody excited
you're here for the first pax east
markiplier panel all right this is a
very special day for me and some of you
may know why it is March 6 and why March
6 is very special you might be asking
yourself is because that that's very
special too but I'm about to Trump your
birthday and I'm sorry I apologize cuz
three years ago today I uploaded my
first video to YouTube you are here on
the three year anniversary of what is
known as markiplier with me that's me
I'm Margot Byron and on this day I
wanted to commemorate something because
three years ago me and Wade over here
who is my very good friend and I love
very dearly he's a great guy
as much as I give him he's one of
the one of the best friends I could
possibly ask for Bob also not trying to
sow dissension Wade's been there for me
a long stay out of this Bob well I'm
gonna stand in between because they
really hate each other Bob's my favorite
actually yeah so um three years ago me
and Wade we came up with this sketch and
it was at the end of a long road of
failed recording but we came up with
this character by the name of Worf sash
and what I have for you today oh wait no
hang on don't put that up yet is that
not up better not be up don't put it up
very upset all my porn is up
how has she been that way don't ask
hey very very flexible okay it's kids in
the audience don't do that are there
Kirby audience yeah this is PG this is a
PG panel anyway we came up with this
character yours about five minutes
that's all you get and what happened is
we made another video where he talks
about five nights at Freddy's so if
we're ready I'm ready I'm ready to play
it now I am ready yes okay you guys
ready okay here we go all right ready
good evening ladies and gentlemen on all
other configurations will be my name is
Will Ferrell Earth has it tonight I
bring you the interview of all the
movies my triumph Herod heard a
hard-hitting
by the well of my special guests had a
security at Freddy fazbear's pizza fungi
hello sir hello yes greetings my main
man hello hello hey howdy greetings
Bonjour
yes well could you briefly explain what
it is you do in Freddy fazbear's Ibiza
sorry about that ladies and gentlemen we
have some technical difficulties but
everything seems to be hunky-dory now Oh
fungi welcome well hi there so give us a
brief description of what one will be
doing if given the opportunity to work
in your position well one would be in
charge of viewing security cameras and
at one point would be in charge of using
telekinetic powers to wind up a music
box so the scary pop-up man doesn't go
boo go boo why that sounds absolutely
frightful what other creepy goings-on
happen around a Freddy fazbear well the
lights flicker quite often there are
grotesque children's drawings posted all
around the office and occasionally you
have to put on a mask so the mechanical
children's animatronics don't forcibly
stuff you into an exoskeleton or or jump
out and go boom
you seem to be strongly in flooring the
amount of booths that occur within your
division yes there are a lot of boots
how many rooms a lot of booths and if
you tell them each anywhere from two to
five booze
I have no idea how you go about dealing
with that many boom what no I said you
close some doors and turn on and off
some lights oh I see well it's come to
my attention that there are some
conspiracy surrounding your restaurant
[Music]
looks like I'll have to get things up
and running yeah because my crew and fan
I like to give someone one thing to do
and the whole show is put in jeopardy
who goes there
need I remind you that I have wilfer
work that I wore shot don't take no
from nobody
[Music]
okay what do you think of that like that
I'm very proud of them I'm very happy
yeah you guys are the first is he even
Bob and wait haven't seen there yet what
are you guys think of that awesome
awesome
I think you've advanced a little bit
since the fall Slenderman a little bit
did I hear the whales of the Damned in
there is that the one for you very good
cuz it came up right as the music as
like everything cut off it was like oh I
didn't add that oh yeah but that was
those shot edited and mostly done by the
cyndago guys if you guys know cyndago at
all they're they're wickedly talented
guys some people don't like him which is
totally fine whatever it's fine but they
we got together and we really planned
this one out we wrote it and we did it
actually before five nights at Freddy's
3 came out we had no idea was coming and
then it was done on the day that the
game was released and we're like oh
perfect it fits in great so this video
is coming up tomorrow so I just wanted
to thank the cynical guys for making it
so please give them a round of applause
because all I did was act and I acted
great I was the best in that and Daniel
was phone guy obviously so now the panel
can officially begin thank you
I have no idea what I'm gonna do after
this I've run out of plans that was the
whole plan as always yes way do you have
any input on want you to be done in this
panel oh we could play solitaire don't
good plays all the time that's a very
good game
Bob any ideas freecell resale also good
good or cards against humanity' we're
not playing that that was a lie oh those
a total lie we're not playing that at
all what do you think there are kids
here already what all right
traditionally people ask questions
things like this yes traditionally mama
was amazing the fact that I could just
yell out a random popular thing and
people would cheer to said to something
else surgeon simulator homework
this away gets over there Bob thank
suggestions pictures of water
microphones college exams wait wait you
are such an unbelievable downer I just
try to think of things I love
ouch cheeseburgers burgers Bob I only do
this I can hear the applause for me and
then you just pop a mile we know you
know okay so anyway what we're gonna do
now is we're gonna take some questions
because that's all we know how to do in
these and then we're gonna answer them
best we can but the reason I have this
is so I can go run into the audience and
talk to you guys so imma do that all the
cameramen are gearing up though Oh No
unhook everything because here I go
like this I could go yay I wanted to
come all the way to the back I know the
cameras won't get me
hey who had a question back here did you
have a question you don't have a
question you're on the spot now hi hi
how are you good good that's a question
huh what'd I do now
I like this anymore did you have a
question yeah did you have a question
you have a question that's not a
question you're failing me yeah question
yes what's your favorite Avenger my
favorite Avenger
it's harkens back to my childhood
he's an unsung hero of the Avengers who
was sorely misrepresented spider-man
and I've heard that he might be in a
future of injuries so no you have a
question oh do you what kind of advice
would you give to another youtuber who's
like starting out to get like some more
subscribers and everything like I say I
had like 7000 subscribers right now
people ask me of that all the time it's
it's a hard question to answer just
because there's a lot of reasons behind
it
hello again hi hello hi thank you
hi thank you yes your love and adoration
means a lot to me okay Jack didn't
high-five me jacksepticeye's here in
yamimash is here and then a bunch of
other youtubers here Matt and what was
your name
tomato name say your name okay
well yeah so um let's just get this out
of the way because it gets asked every
time how do you get started on YouTube
and I'm gonna take a breath and someone
else is gonna answer it I'm very out of
shape
Bob god I'm not a good person to ask
about this because I'm not mad Pat and I
don't know mad Pat I watched his videos
and I've heard what he said I mean the
key really is to do something that you
enjoy as far as I could tell I mean the
obvious booster is to get to know people
who can connect you with their fan bases
and network but the thing that I've
gotten feedback on the most is people my
fans can tell when they watch my videos
whether I like a game or not
and if you're just playing five nights
at freddys because everyone plays it and
that's people want to watch but you you
hate the game and people can tell
they're probably gonna be really turned
off to your videos so aside from knowing
people and networking doing something
you're genuinely interested in is the
main thing I get feedback on but I don't
know how good of a tip that is yeah I
mean I'll expand on that just because it
follows in the general theme that I've
talked about at other panels which is
how to do what you want to do because
not everyone wants to be a youtuber but
other people want to be something more
than what they are like there's nothing
wrong with working in a desk job to get
a paycheck that's totally fine but
there's some people that are right
brained and they're creative and they
want to make
something in the world and they want to
do something and not the left brain
people don't want to do that but like it
often leads into these situations where
it's very hard to make a living off of
what you'd love to do so in those
aspects the youtuber is kind of the same
thing because these days it's very hard
for youtubers to get started like any
other youtuber could tell you I've been
very fortunate I've been very lucky that
have such a great fan base it supports
me and enjoys the videos that I do it
and thank you guys like from the bottom
of my heart I love you guys but you know
without you I would still be making
videos with a few thousand subs I might
be happy but it'd only be a hobby you
know it soared to turn that hobby into
something that you can live off of and
probably the best way to do it is is
just to understand really if it's what
you really want to dedicate your entire
life to and really want to build
everything that you do because when you
have to go and do something like that
you have to sacrifice things and it
sounds ugly that you have to do that but
sometimes you do you have to sacrifice
the ability to make money after
sacrifice friendships you have to
sacrifice your time and the time is the
only thing that you have and when you do
that you always need to understand that
your own minds gonna fight against you
other people are gonna fight against the
other people are gonna tell you it's a
stupid idea it's probably a terribly
stupid idea to try to be a youtuber but
I wouldn't turn a single person away
from it who wanted to do that who really
really had a burning passion to do it
because it's all comes down to what you
really want to do and what you really
truly have a passion for like if you've
got something in your mind that you want
to do I say it pursue it recklessly it
could be the stupidest thing in the
world
I say go for it Sony doesn't hurt
yourself or any other person just do it
because you only have this one life that
was kind of like saying Yolo but
whatever you only have one life to live
in your life one chance to do what you
really want to do but it's also never
too late to start like I tried a dozen
different things before I land on
YouTube Bob can attest to this yeah I
didn't I didn't want to make videos I
was a writer I did comic books I tried
to make art I dropped out of engineering
for a little bit just to pursue art and
I kept trying and trying and it didn't
matter what I was doing because I was
trying to find what I wanted to do what
I was passionate about and so long as
you have that thing if you know and you
will know if you know that that one
thing is the most passion
thing that you could be though and he
got to pursue it because tomorrow might
be too late a little too much rambling
and whatever and I do that so that was
pretty much the same thing Mark said
about three years ago to me that got me
involved yeah he hasn't changed his tune
he's the same guy
yeah Wade's mentioned this story before
that uh we it was actually pretty cool
because my current channel says that I
started on May 22nd and the reason it
says that oh it's 150 oh no what did I
do
so it's 150 right now that's actually a
good way to keep time I'm a genius or
whatever scary so we had a conversation
in mid early May and it was her mid May
and it was right after I lost my first
channel and I just barely got to 2,000
subscribers when like I lost my Adsense
account because of one thing or another
and I was so so very discouraged like
the fact that something I loved was just
taken away from me and not just taken
away but the opportunities that I
thought I had were just taken away from
me
so me and Wade we had this conversation
on a balcony at a friend's house in
we're just talking and we never really
like talked in depth like that before we
talked about our passions and like what
we wanted out of life and what what
really was important at the end of the
day and I really have a lot to thank
Wade about this because I was on the
fence about even continuing to do
YouTube videos because I was like oh man
you know I don't have any money I don't
have a job you really gotta try to do
something here else I'm never gonna be
able to do anything so like I just I
thought I was I was ready to give up I
was ready thank you but I have Wade to
thank for that and Wade really convinced
me that it was what I wanted to do and
if I was what I wanted to do I had to
pursue it even if I had no chance of
what was more amazing is that when I
went back to my channel I put the video
up and I was like hey guys I'm so sorry
but lost this channel I have to start a
new one and like about 650 people which
is oddly the same there were people that
were in that 6,000,000 music video but
650 people followed me they followed me
to my new
and not only did they follow me when I
real uploaded every single video on that
new channel they went through and they
liked every single one of the videos and
they added them back to their favorites
list they watched him again they
rewatching their real comments saying
how much they loved the content that
they didn't want me to give up and it
may not seem like a lot of people now
considering I have six and a half
million subscribers
and which is amazing amazing thank you
guys so much but the fact that six
hundred and fifty people which is less
than the people in this room that many
people thought I was worth following and
that's about the time that I started
realizing that I have a responsibility
to you guys like I have a responsibility
to point you guys in the right direction
and always try to be better for myself
because I'm just one guy and I have
flaws and I can fail and I could do the
wrong thing or I could get lazy but so
long as that I remember that I have you
guys here with me I know that I can do
literally anything so thank you guys
wait now would you please get back to
the silliness and please do your stupid
run to find another question all right
who wants a question everybody get
excited again it's so stupid it's all
I'm here for did you watch our spore
playthrough I have a feeling it would
end up like that that's the best answer
question Bob if you if you were able to
if you were able to make a game whoa its
oh my god wait it's cool
hmm oh my god everyone give me everyone
give me a low steady bring it up bring
it up on stage walk it up on stage walk
it funky wait you didn't walk it you
think so horrifying gonna get us it's
even worse seeing it what what did you
just criticize this panel what'd you say
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's all right
did that mean it was 2 o'clock it were
you upset that I did that oh it's quiet
now how you doing how you doing
everybody thank you Bob
I always win on this but thanks oh we're
gonna do the wave again go go do the way
do it do it do it do it do it okay next
question go get an X let's go sign up
we're gonna do this you're gonna
participate whether you like it or not
in this panel
yeah keep y'all keep going it's coming
back say it's coming back say you look
more energetic more energy more energy
come on
yeah yeah hello welcome to the panel hi
you're already here Oh welcome back to
the panel this for whoever you want to
be for baby I only pay attention what
you guys are so bored what yes can we
continue then huh okay what what what's
your next long Lex play gonna be I don't
know I need to finish fail friend I've
heard that's a good one
oh it's very good yeah I'm very bad at
it but it's very good what item abuse
what's it
okay thank you thank you
wait next next we're we're not we're not
the game grumps you don't hold up all
these - twins oh we got warm stashes in
the house wow that's awesome I'm sorry I
just changed the costume but yay thank
you so much what's a question okay so
the question I have is have any of you
ever built your own computer yeah yeah
what are some of the specs for it huh
for a computer like what are some of the
parts you put into it I cannot
understand you at all what are the part
way do you responsibly gave you the
microphone but didn't tell you huh what
what are the components oh oh well I
built my computer and I also built Wade
and Bob's computers but because I like
to build my own previews cuz my dad
taught me how to build computers when I
was a kid because he was used to be in
the army for computers back when they
took up whole rooms but I don't know
intel processors
memory cards remember a generic non
brain Grasset cards it's really powerful
huh
a disk drive blu-ray am i right or do I
have any HD DVD fans in the in the house
you know old school little bet will be
on everyone's schedules wait you got a
question back there
what you got another question yeah what
is what color would you dye your hair
what color would you tired what color
would I dye my hair he actually dies it
black yeah that's like to cover up the
gray it's actually a what will you make
me the best mother ever and sign my
daughter's shirt for me
I'll go down in a bit yeah in a bit I
know a lot of people want signatures but
I will get to that in a bit if I was
coming down to sign everybody's ass
screw it yeah
oh you right there what am i doing okay
will do
wait get another question
you want a better high-five the
high-five I gave you wasn't good enough
am I asking another question now go
ahead okay all right I'm good out loud
okay wait what's way for the question
markiplier King boss jacksepticeye Bob
Joker wait Queen shut up with white oh
wait no it says shut up like I was a flu
because Superman that's okay I forgive
you I'm Superman
what do you meant right what are you
talking about what gaozong it's a whole
panel going to crap because you don't
know how to run it uh yeah yeah yeah
over here now yeah yes you what is for
all three of you what is the scariest
moment in any game ever the one scariest
moment Bob uh well I don't play scary
games if you watch my channel you and
you've seen my recent videos you know
how tense I get but I think the scariest
moment I've ever experienced was
probably when we were playing gmod
horror and we played the five nights at
Freddy's map yeah the first jump no
reason it was a pretty cheap jump scare
but I actually almost fell out of my
chair that was like my favorite moment
cuz you knocked your green screen back
yeah yeah the gmod scary math that we
played Bob does not play horror games
but he's starting five nights of phrase
right I blame the entire trilogy because
everyone has to now it's required by law
man hello hi how you doing I just want
answer miser high five
hi why what happened you just skipped me
why you just skipped me that's all oh
that was the time okay oh my goodness
okay yes I know you skipped me great
thank you
oh my gosh um I was wondering where you
found your animators for all the
markiplier animator shorts that you do
well where I found my animators licks
ian was like the first one that I found
that really made one that blew me away
so he made an animation about what was
even the game called
I can't even remember psychosis like it
was about psychosis which was this old
rather bad horror game that I played but
it was exceptionally funny yeah
and so I you know I was playing it and I
liked it and then I contacted him and I
asked him you know you know he was gonna
make another one and he did and I was
just like hey you want I'll pay you to
make one so that's what I did you want
high five - all right hmm
I'm sweaty yes
after playing to the moon do you think
you're gonna record the next installment
of the series yes I've heard there's
another one in the in the series already
of to the moon lag if you guys know
about to the moon yes what yeah sure
yeah but um I will the plate to the moon
again you're not gonna give me something
to sign with I don't have any more I
have a question mark what yes I'm out
here now Bob go ahead okay I challenge
you to an arm-wrestle oh my gosh mark
I don't know it was that what I thought
it was hey whoa hey ash you kind of have
to at this point I didn't even hear what
the question was
mark you have an arm-wrestle challenge
oh he threw his club down or smack you
with it or both you you challenged me to
armwrestling
don't know just trying to WWE all right
let's see what happens
hold this for me and no will do it
midair midair Armbrust how do you move
yep Aaron who's on my side to win this
no no let's go up on stage Thanks
challenged me to an arm wrestling
competition I mean have you even seen me
I mean we're gonna do this are you ready
you ready oh yeah you're in midair
yeah I'll lean over like this all right
you got a call this Wade I'm gonna call
it okay all right three two one Russell
are you pulling ask I'm just wondering
cuz we started
or no cheer me on for my strength
[Music]
I can't believe it I lost I don't week
oh he's a champion please please leave
thank you all right thank you for
beating mark I have another question
please get me somebody to embarrass mark
do something to embarrass him
promise me no okay just ask a question
with Bob sing do like games that you
like and I don't know if you've done
this before but you should do a series
on earthbound oh I love earthbound it's
one of my favorites but here's the thing
one thing that opened up a lot of things
for games for me in the future is that I
did that charity livestream and I played
one of my favorite games of all time
Super Mario World
I love that game it didn't seem like I
loved it at the time because I was
exceptionally sick and was weird about
that live stream that live stream made
news headlines like the fact that we
raised money and someone was like
putting false information that I
streamed for 18 hours when in reality I
screamed for three-and-a-half because I
was very sick what I killed Yoshi yes I
did I'm so sorry
he deserved it he did not deserve oh
wait never mind love it another question
please all right here we go you have any
obscure games from like Nintendo or
Super Nintendo that we want to know
about that you'd recommend repeat that
question Bob are there any obscure
Nintendo older Nintendo nests or NES
games you would recommend that we might
not know about oh that's a good question
you guys have any suggestions cuz I
played a lot of rampage all rampages
everyone rampage
rampage for the 64 was also very good
but rampage on the Super Nintendo was
just Oh blowing up buildings eating
people crushing stuff it was the perfect
game for an eight-year-old yeah
anyway but I'd probably but that's one
of my favorites Bobby got another I have
a gift for you you have a gift for me I
wanted to give you a backflip come back
there I'm not gonna do it though all
right well I gotta come back there no no
no stay there he's gonna roll up to you
I was about to run oh he's getting out
of me I'm not sorry oh oh I see all
right oh no no you got yours you you hug
Jack I'm fine why did you what do you
want
don't hurt me again okay okay
you're back look dude so he did a
backflip last year last year but what
are your plans with cyndago in the
future and are you super super excited
to have them in LA with you and what are
your plans for that my plans are to make
a sketch comedy video with them either
on my channel or their channel every
week every week every week yeah we got a
plan we got so many plans in store and
it's gonna be so much fun that was my
original plan anyway and I'm allotting
more time and I'm saving time it's
motivating me to work harder and you're
gonna do a backflip backflip
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hey I'm laughing like you know thank
you guys so much for or thank you guy
for so much for coming out here thanks
guy hey good job guy way to go guy
alright Bobby got another one back there
that's flush one this one's is pretty
serious wow I'm getting like voice
jammer in the back here I got I can't
talk
do you talk it's like the speech jammer
I was wondering what is your most what
would you say is your most formative
game to you positively cuz let's not get
into I'm bread repeat that again for me
Bob
what is our most formative game
individually informative formative for
LeTip like it helped us develop into the
people we are today
formative oh okay what crap would you
like the word I am today
Barbie's Dreamhouse I didn't play that
one Hello Kitty Island Adventure I
played that one word you know all that
game Oh losses I gotta talk about Lucis
that was the most boring game I've ever
played in my life and yet two two
animations came out of it too where's
the blacksmith came out of that game I
probably you haven't even seen that game
I've even said where's the blacksmith in
a long time but formative I don't really
know I I don't know presentable Liberty
was like life-changing in just the way
that it made me question reality
can you stop harassing Jack please are
you are you seriously done here
can I please give my wire you do what
are you doing no no no hi okay no
no Jack don't do it what would you say
to me why were you on my lawn my panel
no no no I've lost control I've lost
control it's over all right Bobby I know
the question back there
uh yeah I've got one right here okay
honestly though honestly no we can't
have this I'm so sorry seriously no go
back to your seats I'm so sorry yeah
mark yes what's the most embarrassing
story you have for us what what's the
most embarrassing story you have to tell
us today
embarrassing the one that I tell you in
front of everyone my most embarrassing
story okay here we go
entice I'm so excited how exactly I'm
embarrassing oh thank you
Oh Bob all right okay all right now that
that's over with
it's a most embarrassing story I don't
know wait I'd have to think about this
one cuz I had a lot of embarrassing
moments there was a time when I was a
young lad about like seven or eight and
I went out to the bus with no pants
really that good why a cup and I was
running late and I forgot to grab pants
and I rushed out the door my back Tiny's
I oh I know I know my favorite
embarrassing story oh you remember how
there was opposite day yes in Milford
yeah well I went all out for opposite
day I went nuts for oppas a day I had
shorts and like a ratty t-shirt on one
side I cut a tie in half put it in a
dress shirt inside out put dress pants
inside out and only one half was dressy
the other half was like jean shorts and
or not little shorts and a she shirt
that day was not opposite day I miss I
misread the calendar the next day was
opposite day so and what was even worse
was that it for king of the werecats Bob
you have oh yeah ass when you became
King oh okay oh the way cats doing all
the way it's not a good chat wait Bob
the king Bob the king Bob King yeah it's
on crooked
turn it 90 degrees to your left yes
thank you yes King in the North King in
the North King in the north
it's the king in the north okay Bob you
have an embarrassing story
I know hi no embarrassing stories no I
won't tell them no no okay all right I'm
going in I'm going down
[Applause]
whoa yeah whoa I hope that was caught on
camera what you were doing I hope so too
I'll do it again okay hang on that's
good right that's good all right
hypothetically if someone had a youtube
channel maybe named mama prove Let's
Plays how would they contact you or any
other bigger youtuber to do a collab
like what's the best way try this a
complicated situation because like I
know and it's not that it's embarrassing
to ask it's like we as YouTube it's like
me Bob and Wade we play together because
we're really close friends and we really
like playing with close friends and the
thing about being a youtuber it's hard
to get close to people it's kind of the
unfortunate thing like I have so many
fans but I have to be careful for a lot
of reasons and I have to know that
someone doesn't just want to be my
friend to use my channel or something
and I'm not saying that you have that
you know in mind but it's just hard to
get someone to enter that circle but it
happens because yamimash and
jacksepticeye
and d live it under one of those guys up
there they're really good friends of
mine
I call them really close friends because
they you know they they approached me
like a human you know they didn't
approach me like here's the most godly
youtuber in the world no they approached
me and I liked their videos and we just
talked like that like I reached out to
Jack and then Yami reached out to me
when his channel was bigger than mine
like young master Channel I looked up to
him because he was like oh my god you
you when you do slender it's just so
funny and like then slender died out and
then I passed him in subs and I hope
he's not you know we don't feel bad
about that all because I love young mesh
to death like he's really really cool
guy and and I hope you guys watch him
too because he's awesome
she and Jack Jack's okay Jack's okay
guys okay yeah Yami great anyway so it's
just like that just have good oh you
want me your card oh okay you were
already in the in the the tongue cam I
guess hey hey I was go
yeah but you have a serious question yes
that's that's weird so I just want to
say this with recent events I have
recently found out that you know like
for instance I'm losing my home so in
the light of things I have noticed some
things are very important I you know do
my own thing I'm not gonna say my name
or what I do but I have people that
support me and you have so many people
that support you jack has people Bob
Wade everyone has people and you have to
have helped people but I'm wondering
have we helped you because there are
some dark times everyone has in their
life and I'm hoping that we've helped
you just as much as we you have felt us
oh yeah oh yeah that's no question about
that I'm sorry that you're going through
such rough times I wish I could help you
individually but yeah no I mean as
people know I've been through I need to
get out of this my goodness anyway I've
been through a lot of really dark times
in my life oh thank you
I've been through a lot of really dark
times and I hate to say that you know I
I hate to say that you know I hate to
try to mope about it because I always
try to move past but like just thank you
what was that you're a lovely pers so
are you yeah but it was just you it's
just very what huh
I I was I was answering a question there
no you can ask it I'm sorry
photos everybody sweet um when it goes
when it goes on three nine something
something something um I think that's
well it's being trap goes like took him
to camo three to camo 9 and then to camo
five and then whatever no that's it
that's actually a good guess but it's
actually not I just released a video was
released today of me getting the good
ending it's all part of that and there's
a secret in there but thank you I'm not
I'm answering another question here I
was in the middle of an emotional spiel
I was spilling my guts ever
my goodness I'm not done you sit down
I'm alright hang on wait man let me let
me say this let me finish lime juice let
me finish let me finish baby let me
finish let me finish let me finish let
me finish let me finish I've already got
too excited you know I'm good calm down
a little bit
everybody take a deep breath breathe now
breathe in now people are holding their
breath now breathe out oh hi wait anyway
so what I was saying is you guys helped
me through dark times in my life that's
it okay we're done all right cool all
right
so anybody else how much time we got
what time is it where's my 12 minutes
what we had this agreement we got 280 we
got - 72 72 18 - 18 through 70 what time
is it - 18 - 18 - 8 hello Matt Granger
72 72 82 engine 130 130 we got 130 over
there you want something you got seven
seven over there seven eight you got
seven we had seven you got a five I got
five five five five five whole bunch of
pies - we got two got eight eight okay
like a ya'll just went along with that
what's wrong with you people
I don't understand you we've got very
little time left so Bob what would you
like to do for the last little bit that
we got here boxer briefs i I think I
mean we gone to a lot of questions but
there are a lot of people with their
hands up you want to do speed questions
like we did at the end of the last one
well that would require both me and Wade
running out there okay what we're gonna
do is for the next until we have like
two minutes left we're gonna do speed
questions to mean we're gonna get there
we're gonna answer it as fast as
possible I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
this row in between a and C you get B in
C hallway and then we'll go to the
outskirts of it I'm gonna start the back
work my way up
you get all start in the front and work
my way back okay okay go go go
yes speed question yeah
will you marry me why no hang on get you
all Alexis dolefully you marry me whoo
yes
dude you just made me the happiest guy
in the world thank you
oh man I'm like dude this is the second
sim here that is the second time that's
happened
does anyone else have a proposal to make
I don't want to walk all over that one
but I feel like that's an important
thing we should have got to early on I I
wish I would have known man I had no
idea yeah okay wait wait
yeah question speak we got one right
here selfie yes oh he's doing a selfie
yes you who inspires you
oh all of you know uh other youtubers
who are better than me which is like all
of them I just want to say hi from
Hartwick College gaming club and we love
you absolutely we do we did five nights
Freddy's like gaming competition we just
love you I did congratulations I have a
gaming club okay okay wait what yeah go
on
so I'm a big retro gamer I gotta ask
Nintendo or Sega Nintendo why not pop
Nintendo wait I said both I like both
true you you you you can to do a lot of
hot sauce challenges what'd you do with
the remaining hot sauce burn it no no I
got another challenge you'll get a free
preview my next challenge is gonna be
called the fire and ice challenge guess
what that means fire in the hole oh wait
hang up old on Wayde
yeah next okay wait did you bring your
Cool Ranch Doritos he's just got a bag I
just got a bag Bobcats will save us does
anyone have a question for Bob I'll get
to you in a second
question for Bob you have a question for
Bob okay I'll be right back all right I
actually was thinking about setting up a
YouTube channel and I wanted to wonder
what it's like to have a marriage at the
same time as having a YouTube channel
and going to law school
how's that like Bob uh well the marriage
is not that detrimental to YouTube I
think
Manny didn't know I was gonna do YouTube
going in cuz I didn't start that until
after but she knows that I'm a gamer and
she's supportive of me doing what I want
to do so that's not that hard
as long as I'm you know I don't forget
that she exists I make time for both the
harder thing is law school you pretty
much have to pick either between going
to school or doing YouTube stuff and
you're always not doing something you
should be for the other one that's the
sacrifice well there's no there's not
enough hours in the day to do both yeah
I mean it's hard to juggle anything like
that let alone in college and to go for
an and doing YouTube it's all very
time-consuming okay wait you got a
question back there
yeah one mark first engineering that's
what I went to school for might as well
use it Bob Bob was a question if you
weren't doing YouTube what would you do
either being a lawyer or running a
non-profit I'd also be an attorney I was
going to law school you were just such
an inspirational person to I think all
of us here and millions of others who
couldn't be here and you seem to get a
lot of enjoyment out of helping people I
have ever thought for running for public
office or a position like that where you
can really be out there because I
thought about that I honestly thought
about that like I could run for say
senator in some district and in some
state I could run for Senator and I
might have a competing chance but to be
honest I'd rather make a difference in
the world than be in political office
like
I'd rather you know do my own thing and
there go all of our political fans so I
don't speak about policies alright go on
what God and I try to lick my elbow
right here wait what are you doing back
there
what does wait do we do it Wade's not
okay back there for some reason I can't
do it
wait are you trying to lick your elbow
yeah I tried she can I love you thank
you okay what time is it time time what
time - 24 - 24 wait we got to get back
on the bus stage a stage exactly my age
does anyone else have any
earth-shattering announcements to make
on the lines of marriage proposals like
I'm shocked like I thank you so much for
predicting my panel do they like him
what yes yes can I give you a kiss on
the cheek
all right this is the last five how much
time we got five minutes five minutes we
got last five minutes which means we've
got ten minutes so we got ten minutes
left in this panel so what are we gonna
do for the last sentence I'll leave this
up to Bob and we cuz I usually like
about Bob I I do too much stuff Bob Bob
please tell us how we're gonna end this
panel because at what this is the third
panel we've done and each one has been
more fun than the last and I gotta be
honest you guys are fantastic for
filling this room and this room is huge
and I hope you enjoyed the video at the
beginning but I want Bob to really help
us out and finish this off strong so
finish it off with a great joke Bob make
them all laugh so hard that they pee
their pants
tears streaming down their face all
right go so Martin prepare me for this
so my joke is actually Wade I'm the joke
my joke is I got him thank you it's hard
to say
I'm Florida at that like that's amazing
I wish I wish I had something to give
you because the last time someone
proposed at the last panel that we had
in San Antonio and I had something to
give them but I don't have anything to
give you here like wait come up on stage
YouTube come up on stage come up on
stage
I totally missed it so oh no yes are you
oh no no okay come on come on Bond stage
well don't intercept him before they get
up here but I'm a football player all
right come up here coming up here come
here come here come here let Uncle Mark
congratulate you on your proud beautiful
matter
you really did a great job here I don't
know what is your name James
Alexis James and Alexis I want everyone
in here this is the only gift that I can
give because you're all here I want
everyone in here to wish them the
happiest marriage in the world and
happiness for the rest because that
makes this incredible cup of water I got
some money I could give you like like if
there's anything I could give you guys
like I got everything I need with her is
the sweetest thing I've ever heard Jos
already here wait let me get look at
this that's good there's a sentimental
moment I feel I feel at the squad you
want I feel this yeah my butt sticking
out and like just strutting my chest
forward so just thank you give them
another round of applause thank you guys
for someone for coming up
thank you for letting it oh absolutely I
wish
yeah no problem oh man that's really
cool is that so we're done with
questions unfortunately I know a lot of
people had questions and I wish we could
get to everything but there's so many
people here yes what - 27 - 27 okay
- 27 so Bob do you have any other ideas
for how you want to finish what thank
you thank you thank you
that's a weird circle okay so I was just
thinking I'm always bummed out at these
at the end because there's no way we
could possibly answer everyone's
questions and I have my druthers we
would let each of you ask whatever
question you had or say hi or say that
you love mark or whatever but if we
couldn't get to your question even if we
could I think it's a nice way to end
just by saying thank you
I know mark says thank you a lot and I
know this is marks panel and we're just
here as guests it's mark and friends and
it's an honor to be here thank you buddy
thank you but I know mark will echo
anything that I say but I like to take
an opportunity to thank all of you for
coming this this is such a big room full
of people I it's so cool to see you guys
I hope that you all come to the signing
if you still have stuff to say because I
will talk to every single one of you
we're not gonna leave until we talk to
you guys yeah we're gonna be here the
whole weekend so if you see us please
topless even if we seem like we just
harass us grab us no don't do that but
like I always I always feel sentimental
grab gently I'm just so it's such a cool
thing to be able to be here and have you
guys wanting to talk to us even if you
only want to talk to mark everyone
that's leaving is gonna miss the big
surprise again but
so I just wanted to say thank you I
don't know what mark wants to do to end
it but that's cool yeah I wanted on the
bottom of my heart what we're gonna do
is we're gonna end this with Wade giving
us a serenade he's prepared too small
for us he's really been practicing I'm
dead serious he's been singing this song
for ages he's almost annoyed me to death
like contacting me about this and
singing this preparing this special song
for you guys I'm totally not making this
up here we go I'm really sorry that this
is the end of the panel Zoe and I could
have kept going
[Music]
you